CHRIS MANNING: Thanks,
everybody, for coming.
Really excited to
welcome our author Summer
Brennan to Google.
My name is Chris Manning.
I'm on the legal
team here at Google,
and I'm also a huge
environmental advocate,
which is how I came to
invite Summer to Google.
And I'm really, really excited
to hear her talk about some
of the history of Drake's
Bay Oyster Farm, and some
of Point Reyes's history,
and the history of oysters
in the area.
So I hope it'll be exciting
for you guys as well.
Summer is an author.
This is her first
book, "The Oyster War."
She's also had a number of
stories and other publications,
such as "McSweeney's," "the
Rumpus," and "The Believer
Logger."
So she's been doing
this for a little while.
She writes professionally for
the United Nations Press Office
as well.
So again, she's got
some experience,
and I'm really excited to
talk about her first book,
"The Oyster War."
So I'm going to go ahead
and welcome you up, Summer.
We're going to do a Q&A
conversation between the two
of us, back and forth.
And additionally, Summer's
going to read a little bit
from her book.
SUMMER BRENNAN: A tiny bit.
CHRIS MANNING: What's that?
SUMMER BRENNAN: I
said, just a tiny bit.
CHRIS MANNING: Yeah,
just a tiny bit,
just to give you guys the
flavor of her writing style
and also just what's
going on in the book.
And we'll use that an intro.
So without further ado,
Summer, welcome to Google.
SUMMER BRENNAN:
Thank you so much.
CHRIS MANNING: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
SUMMER BRENNAN:
Well, I guess this
is a great way of a
tiny introduction.
I don't know if anyone's heard
of what this book is about.
There was a conflict inside
Point Reyes National Seashore--
which is just north of here.
Some of you may know it--
about an oyster farm that
had been there for a while,
and whether or not it
would get to stay past 2012.
And so this story seemed like
a little tempest in a teapot,
but it actually ended up
getting all this national press
and almost went to the Supreme
Court, and it was a big thing.
So I wrote a book about it.
And chronologically, it
stretches rather widely.
I think it goes back to
sometimes BC at some points,
just because I'm trying
to get a little bit
of the geological history and
the anthropological history
the area.
So I thought I'd just
read just one paragraph
at the start of chapter three.
So actually, this goes
back to the 19th century.
OK, so I'll just read.
So it's the fable of
the California oyster.
The oyster pirates preferred to
ambush the beds by moonlight.
Working mostly in pairs,
with two men per vessel,
they mustered together
in ramshackle armadas
of 30 or 40 small boats.
They waited until
cloudless nights,
when the full moon
shone brightly
on the piles of
pale shells onshore,
before advancing on the oyster
companies' camps en masse,
their pistols at the ready.
They went by nicknames, like
the Porpoise, the Centipede,
the Spider, or the Shark.
One particularly
vicious character,
known for trying to tear off
the faces of his opponents
in hand-to-hand combat, was
known simply as Scratch.
Their ranks included
petty thieves
and notorious murderers,
fisherman gone
crooked and adventuring youths.
And in 18 1897,
among their number
was a 20-year-old
undercover fish patrol
agent by the name of
John Griffith Cheney,
better known to you
and me as Jack London.
So just a little taste.
Then it goes on from there.
CHRIS MANNING: Very awesome.
A good taste of the local
flavor that I think this book
definitely offers.
And being in the
Bay Area, I think
it's very, very appropriate.
So you mentioned a
little bit about what
the overall story is about.
Can you tell us why it
was such a big deal?
What was going on
here that pulled
on both sides of the community
that really made this
such a contentious issue?
SUMMER BRENNAN: Sure.
Well, I mean, everybody
got involved with it
for different,
individual reasons.
You can't speak for
anyone on either side.
But on the one hand, which can
be called the pro-oyster farm
camp, the argument
was that bad science
had been used to imply or
prove that this oyster farm was
environmentally
detrimental, and so they
were trying to push it out.
And so they saw this is a bigger
story about an out of control
government that was acting
capriciously and picking
on the little guy in some sense.
And so that was on the one hand.
And the other hand,
there was concern
that because this was inside
a wilderness area, not just
a national park,
that it would create
a very dangerous precedent for
future wilderness protection.
And we've never had a wilderness
area taken away or undone,
so this would have been the
first time that that would've
been compromised in some way.
And so even if
people liked the farm
or thought it wasn't harmful
to allow it to continue,
that was the fear,
that it could open up.
As you get into it
in the story, they
weren't the only people that
thought that might be something
they could do with it.
CHRIS MANNING: Cool.
Well, since we're at Google
and you mentioned science,
I borrowed a
question-- I'll call
it borrowed, really stealing-- a
question from another interview
that I read about this book,
actually, that I thought
was really interesting, just
around the question of science.
So what kind of
research, to start off,
what kind of
research did you have
to do scientifically to sort
of understand both sides
what was going on here?
SUMMER BRENNAN: Well, there was
a lot of science reports done
around this, and
in my appendices,
I have nine of them
listed, because those
were the key ones, and
people were confused.
What's going on?
So I didn't do any
scientific research myself,
but I surveyed the reports
that went out about it.
And they were
basically just trying
to discern what's the impact
to this fragile ecosystem
from this company?
But mostly they were
from secondary sources,
so there was very little
primary research being gathered.
And it was
interesting to see how
these older studies
or things that
were done elsewhere and
repurposed for this area
were rehashed and spun
out in different ways
that some people
thought were good
and other people were
very critical of.
CHRIS MANNING: In a topic like
this about the environment
and more biologically
speaking, do
you feel that maybe you
came to understand some
of the limitations
of science and how it
might apply this type of field?
SUMMER BRENNAN:
Well, I guess it just
depends on what kind of
science you're doing.
One of the most interesting
things about this conflict,
actually, was how people had
maybe higher expectations
of certain scientific
processes than were
realistic for the situation.
So to understand that these
things are an evolving process,
and sometimes scientists
do make mistakes.
So there was a spotlight
on this whole thing.
So if anybody messed
up or interpreted
a study a different
way, it was seen
as maybe it was intentional.
And so it drifted away from the
more collaborative and evolving
process that so much of
the biological sciences
are, where you work with
what information you can
and just keep going from there.
CHRIS MANNING: So it spun in
different directions and things
like that based on the side.
I think it's probably
generally true.
So how did you get of
involved with the story?
What captivated you
about it, or how did you
get your intro in it?
SUMMER BRENNAN: So I grew up out
near Point Reyes in West Marin.
And I went east for
college, but before then, I
grew up out there.
And I had never heard
of this conflict before.
I knew of the oyster farm,
and obviously the park.
But I got tired of living in
New York City after a while.
I've been working
there for a long time.
And I decided to move
back home for a while.
So I got a job at a local paper,
and this was the main story
they were working on.
So I got thrown into the mix
and right away introduced
to key people and
sent hundreds of pages
of research and opinion.
So it was a lot.
CHRIS MANNING: Great.
Yeah, it definitely
sounds like it probably
would have been a lot
to take on all at once.
SUMMER BRENNAN: It
was fascinating.
CHRIS MANNING: Cool.
Did you have any
initial feelings
when you went into it about
maybe how you would have sided
with one side or the other?
Or did you just
really try to let
the facts speak for themselves?
SUMMER BRENNAN: I
would think of myself
as being in the latter camp,
but without realizing it,
I was just dropped
right into the middle
of the pro-oyster farm group,
because the paper was working
as a support
system, and had ties
to people that were some
of its main advocates.
So yeah.
I started out very
much mostly just
hearing that one
side of the story
and reasons in favor
of the oyster farm.
And not just the farm itself,
but the separate issue
of why it should
be able to stay.
So my views of it changed
over time with more research.
CHRIS MANNING: OK, Cool.
You've alluded to this
a little bit I think,
but can you elaborate
a little bit more
on maybe some of the people
that were involved in the story,
or how you got to know
them during the research
process and that kind of
thing, and just why they
felt so vehemently
one side or the other?
SUMMER BRENNAN: Sure.
I guess there's a couple
different questions there.
In terms of the people that are
involved, for writing the book,
I had to choose people from
different sections of groups
that were involved
in this to highlight,
because there were
so many people
involved-- ranching community,
and different people
in the agricultural
community, environmentalists.
And so while many of them
are mentioned in the book,
I had to pick out a
story from each faction,
so to speak, to it
to illustrate it.
So there's a rancher
in here who's
a friend of mine, Joey Mendoza,
and he's a third generation
cattleman.
He actually just passed
away a couple weeks ago,
unfortunately.
So I tell his family
history in here
to give the voice of some of
the agricultural community
and their experiences.
I don't know.
And I picked one of
the environmentalist
to highlight, and et cetera,
and with the oyster family.
And just in terms of why people
were so enthusiastic about it,
or passionate
about this, I think
it varied, but I did
get a sense of a panic
about the way their
world is changing,
and a sense of
running out of space,
or running out of time to
protect certain things,
whether that's
small family farming
or environmental
protection of areas.
And that's one of things
that really drew me to it.
I do think we're at this
juncture where people
are realizing we really
do have to take action
on a lot of this, because
they're seeing these things get
steamroll.
CHRIS MANNING: So
there's some other oyster
farms in Point Reyes as well.
Folks here may have been to the
them, Tomales Bay, Hog Island.
Those groups, were they a
part of this story at all,
or did they have a stake in
the legal claim or anything?
SUMMER BRENNAN: Well, they
were especially at the end.
Tomales Bay Oyster Company ended
up being part of a lawsuit.
A bundle of companies ended
up launching their own lawsuit
at the end, because
they were arguing
that the closure to
Drake's Bay Oyster Farm
would impact their
own businesses.
But that lawsuit was dismissed
as frivolous by the judge.
But it's a community of people,
of neighbors and friends.
And they wanted to support
people that they knew,
so they definitely had
a lot of local support.
CHRIS MANNING: To
that point, I think
this is a very local story
that you're describing here,
but did you find that there were
also a lot broader implications
in some ways?
And what were those?
SUMMER BRENNAN: I did.
And as I think I was
getting at a little,
we're at a time
where we're trying
to figure out how we're going
to manage lands that are left.
And I think people are
realizing that our ideas of what
wilderness means
are fairly outdated.
I mean, the Wilderness
Act is from 1964,
and the way we talk
about wilderness
is a bit-- not to get
academic on people,
but it's very much rooted
in the colonial ideas,
and it's very a sense of "we
as Europeans came and found
this Eden that was untouched by
man," which is completely false
and a myth.
There were hundreds of
thousands of people living here.
And from the first
contact with Europeans,
the population was much,
much higher, but diseases.
winnowed the population down
so much that by the time
there was a huge influx
of Europeans, obviously,
especially Gold
Rush Era here, what
had been a very thriving human
population was diminished.
So there's these false ideas
that we have about wilderness
being untouched, or
being a place where
people can't co-exist.
And so I think it's
time to reevaluate
those kinds of thoughts.
And anyway, I'm
rambling, but I think
that that was at the
heart of this story,
of arguing what
belongs in wilderness
and what is a wilderness.
SUMMER BRENNAN: Yeah,
I think absolutely.
It may seem silly,
I guess, but just
from my own background and
studying history and things
like that, there's a
whole academic distinction
between the John Muir camp,
and the Gifford Pinchot camp,
and that kind of thing.
So yeah, it's out there.
CHRIS MANNING: Cool.
So what sort of initial response
have you gotten to the book
so far?
I imagine there's
obviously heated response
in some regards in Point Reyes,
but overall, on a larger level,
has it been generally positive?
SUMMER BRENNAN: Yes, I'm
really pleased, actually.
We were wondering when
we were making this book,
is anyone going to care
about this little thing?
But it's been really great,
and living in New York,
I've heard from a lot of people
in the publishing industry
there that have enjoyed it.
So it's been getting
some great press.
Obviously, locally, it was just
such a contentious, divisive
issue that people that
were on the losing side
are not thrilled to have the
story all laid out like this.
CHRIS MANNING: Cool.
That's awesome.
I hope the audience
will humor me
a little bit that I have a few
questions that are specifically
about writing and your
process with writing.
Can you share a little
bit about your process.
And since this is
your first book,
as I mentioned a
couple of times,
did you find that any
tactics particularly
worked for you in the process?
SUMMER BRENNAN: I did.
I don't know if anyone here
is a writer other than having
a regular job, but that's what
I was doing for part of this.
And I read somewhere
that nobody wants
to hear about how hard
it is to write a book,
because people think
it's a privileged thing
to be able to do.
But it's all true
how hard it is,
and I think for a
first book especially.
But actually, last summer, I
was having a lot of difficulty
with the writing process.
And it just seemed
insurmountable.
And there was so
much information
that I was trying to distill.
I mean, for every
page on this book,
there's probably 100
pages of research
that we needlessly did.
But still, just that
process was overwhelming.
And I ended up taking an online
course with Susan Orlean, who's
a writer.
And it was just pre-recorded,
and it seems silly,
but she had the best advice
for how to work in nonfiction
and taking this volume of
information from your research
and distilling it down to
your notes, and typing it up,
and just very methodical.
And so I adapted and
adopted that approach.
And so it was unrefined
research, and then notes
and typed notes, and then
cards and moving them around.
And so it was a very
organized process in that way,
but that really helped me
to actually finish the book.
CHRIS MANNING: No,
that's awesome.
All you budding nonfiction
writers out there,
Susan Orlean online course.
Is that what it is?
SUMMER BRENNAN: Yeah, I'm
advertising for Skillshare,
but it was on Skillshare.
It was really, really
great, and it helped me.
I was about here, and it helped
me get all the way to the end.
CHRIS MANNING: Cool.
Very awesome.
Well, I think you spoke to how
hard it is to write a book,
but can you also mention some
of the other things that maybe
aren't a part of the writing,
but still are part of
getting the book out there?
I understand you did
an Indiegogo campaign
to help fund the book as well.
So there's a whole business
side and things like that
that you had to take on.
SUMMER BRENNAN: Yeah.
Well, as people may
be aware, publishing
is not the richest
industry, or at least as
compared to what it has been.
So people talk
about book advances
maybe not being what
they used to be.
I don't know.
This is my first one.
But that's what I've heard.
And it's very hard to
do a book like this that
requires a lot of research.
So it's not just
something I could
do-- I mean, I know novels
also take travel and research,
so I don't mean to
disparage that at all.
But I had to go to
places physically
and do a lot of
research that could only
happen at a research library
during particular hours
during the day.
And so it was hard to fund it.
So I ran out of
money to work on it,
but I didn't want to give up.
So yeah, I did an
Indiegogo campaign
and raised a little over $3,000.
To it seems small,
but when you're
operating on a
shoe-string budget
and just trying to
get to the next thing,
it helped a lot, actually.
CHRIS MANNING: My
role models as authors
and in the academic
world are female.
And as a follower
of yours on Twitter,
I've liked seeing that
some of your conversations
are around topics of
being a female author.
SUMMER BRENNAN: I talk
about feminism a lot.
CHRIS MANNING: Can
you share anything
more about maybe
your perspective
about being a female author?
Or maybe if there's any
challenges or unique things
that you've faced
in that capacity?
SUMMER BRENNAN:
Well, I've only been
a published author for a couple
weeks now, so I'm new at it.
What can I share?
What's the question?
What's it like?
CHRIS MANNING: Yeah.
What's your perspective like?
Did you feel like
you encountered
any different challenges, or was
it a pretty standard process?
SUMMER BRENNAN: I think so.
I don't know if I
should talk about them.
No, I mean, I don't
know if people
are familiar with Rebecca
Solnit, the author,
but she has a great,
famous essay called
"Men Explain Things to Me."
And it's interesting.
It's an interesting read.
So I think sometimes there is
a bit of ingrained cultural
things that people
don't necessarily
realize they're doing.
And so people will explain
my own subject to me
and sort of assume ignorance.
And I'm like, I did
write a book about it,
but thank you for sharing.
Well, you know, you
don't want to be rude,
and people mean well.
And so I don't think it's
malicious most of the time.
And I'm not a total
spring chicken,
but I'm relatively
young for authors,
and so that might
be part of it too.
But I'm still brand
new, so I'm sure I'll
have lots of other
horror stories
to tell as time goes on.
Or not.
Hopefully not.
CHRIS MANNING:
Yeah, hopefully not.
But no, that's cool.
I think particularly
with a topic that
was so contentious
to begin with,
where people had such
personal feelings about it,
I think it's interesting.
SUMMER BRENNAN: Absolutely.
Well, there's somebody
that was in the book that's
been critical of the book, and
doesn't agree with the things
that I have laid out.
And so I think that
I did my research.
I have a bibliography.
It's all there.
CHRIS MANNING:
It's professional.
SUMMER BRENNAN: Right.
But anyway, it's interesting.
CHRIS MANNING:
Yeah, that's great.
One of the quotations
that starts out
the book is "everything
not saved will be lost."
And it's a line from Nintendo,
as you put it in there.
How do you understand that quote
in the context of your story?
SUMMER BRENNAN: So everything
not saved will be lost
is such a great big
accidentally deep phrase.
And when I came across it,
I'm not the first person
to repurpose that, but I was
really struck by it, especially
since what I felt was
at the core of this book
was a fear of loss
of different kinds,
whether it was of this
particular farm or a type
of way of life, small
farming, or the environment,
that it was just this
sense of urgency.
Maybe I'm taking it too
literal, but that's just really
what I got from it, is just
this wake-up call of everything
not saved will be lost.
And it's fun that it's Nintendo.
CHRIS MANNING: Definitely.
Since we're in the
Bay Area, we're
in a time right now
of expensive housing.
Sometimes, the environment
seems to become an issue
in that in that
maybe we shouldn't
protect certain area because
we should build housing there.
We should build something
to help the economy
and that type of thing.
Do you think that
the conversation
around what it means to be wild
and where the environment is
in a time right now, how do
you see that playing out,
I guess, in the story,
but also, I guess,
more holistically
on a larger scale?
SUMMER BRENNAN: Oh, sure.
Well, I mean, it definitely
was a big issue in the story,
because that was the
question, of course.
Are we going to have this
place for something commercial
that is going to be an element
in the community in terms
of creating jobs and
foods and all that stuff?
Or whether it can be set
aside for the environment?
And obviously, that
is a big issue.
And with the economic
problems, it's
easy to argue for supporting
economies over the environment.
But the problem is that once
you destroy an ecosystem,
it's incredibly difficult if
not impossible to restore it.
But everything is
damaged at this point.
I mean, there isn't really
any intact ecosystem anywhere
in America as they
would have existed
300 years ago because
of invasive species
from big animals to tiny plants.
But it's a question that's
coming up everywhere, I think.
CHRIS MANNING: So
my final question--
and then I'm hoping that maybe
some folks in the audience
have some questions as well--
is hopefully a fun one.
Do you have a
favorite oyster style?
Do you like oysters?
SUMMER BRENNAN: Oh gosh.
So I love oysters, and yes, I
actually like them just raw.
So that's my favorite
way to have them.
But I like especially
if they have
a little bit of the liqueur
still left in the shell.
So yeah, I eat oysters a lot.
It's great.
They're really
having a renaissance,
especially in New York.
It almost seems like everywhere
has an oyster happy hour now.
So it's a good place to stop in.
CHRIS MANNING: Do you have
a favorite oyster place
that you used to go for them?
SUMMER BRENNAN: Well, actually,
I love Grand Central Oyster
Bar in Midtown.
When I work at the
UN, it's close by.
So it's a nice place
on the way home to--
CHRIS MANNING:
How about locally?
SUMMER BRENNAN: Yeah?
Oh, locally?
I think my favorite--
well, I don't
want to-- they're all great.
I like all the oyster farms.
I especially like Hog
Island Oyster's sweetwaters.
Hog Island sweetwaters, I think
that's what they're called.
They're excellent.
If you haven't them,
definitely give it a try.
CHRIS MANNING: Cool.
Does anybody in the
audience have any questions
they'd like to ask Summer?
Great.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
SUMMER BRENNAN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so
much for being here.
It was great to see you.
I lived in [INAUDIBLE]
from 2008 to 2012,
and I came to a couple of town
halls, and I knew some people.
And whenever people asked
me about the story, what's
happening, I would be like, I
don't even know where to start.
It's so complicated.
And I'm curious.
Even today, you presented most
of your thoughts as questions.
It's just something that
we're grappling with.
It's really hard to understand.
So I'm curious--
I'm looking forward
to buying your book today--
how you lay the story out
and how you decided
is it chronological?
SUMMER BRENNAN: So it jumps
around a little, actually.
And I tried to think of it
in the planning of the story.
Well, first, I actually laid
everything out chronologically
in my notes.
So I made a massive timeline
that was like 8,000 BC,
Miwoks settle in Olema.
And then the most
recent was January 1st,
oyster farm is gone.
And then included
within that timeline
was everybody's birthdays and
death dates and everything.
And then I switched it around.
So your question
was chronological.
It's quite chronological
towards the end,
because it sort of just
is the momentum of moving
through this story,
where it's local,
and suddenly, you've got Koch
brother attorneys coming in,
and the Supreme Court,
and then all these people.
But it does jump around a
bit, and you going along
chronologically,
and then I step back
to Sir Francis Drake at the
beginning of the next section.
AUDIENCE: What would you say
the lasting impact of this
has been on the
community in Port Reyes?
SUMMER BRENNAN: Oh gosh.
Well, I think that's still
being figured out to a degree.
It's still a very hotly
contested, debated issue.
And with the book coming
out, it's flared up,
and there's been some angry
things in the newspaper
and people that violently
dislike the book,
and other people that are
absolutely thrilled with it.
So locally, I think it has
created some lasting divisions
between some people in
the agricultural community
and in the
environmental community.
There's some trust
that's been lost there.
And with the National
Park too, people
that feel that they
handled this very badly,
they're nervous about
anything that they do.
So there's other issues popping
up with Tule elk management
and different things that
require public input that I
think that they're
trying to soothe over,
but those tensions are
still felt, I think.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
SUMMER BRENNAN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So I guess my
question is from maybe a broader
perspective.
Throughout the course
of your research,
obviously, one of
the like the core
tenets that we're grappling
with is the rise of agriculture
and how that fits in
with our environment.
Were you optimistic
as you learned more
about modern farming techniques?
And do you feel
like these two are
going to be able to
reconcile in the future
where we can have a successful
and large society that
reconciles with our environment?
SUMMER BRENNAN: Yeah, I
mean, I work with this stuff
a little bit with
the UN as well.
And I think what's encouraging
is that we have the technology
to do all these
things sustainably,
even our energy production
and transportation.
It's just a question
of implementing
the systems is my take on it.
And that's the same with
agriculture as well.
So there's different obstacles
to that, and some of them
are finances.
And at other times,
there are just
people that are in
powerful positions,
or they have industries that
they don't want to see go.
So that's where
you run into-- it's
hard to make that
transition, I think.
So it's technically possible.
I just hope that we can make it
economically possible as well.
And this was a lot about
fisheries, the agriculture,
but it's an oyster farm.
So I had to look a lot at that.
And I we do need to
drastically change
how we handle fishing and
seafood, because fish stocks,
I think, are projected
to collapse in 50 years
if we don't change.
So I hope we can change that.
CHRIS MANNING: I'd be interested
in how your for at the UN
has also influenced
some of the stuff
that you were able to
write in this story.
Did you find that to
be the case at all?
Maybe the systems thinking part?
SUMMER BRENNAN: I think
it helped me to take
a bit of a step back from it.
Working as a reporter
in Point Reyes,
I started in 2012, so I
guess you were still there.
You know, you can get a little
myopic about the whole thing,
but when you step back
and look at the bigger
picture in the context of
climate change, and ocean
acidification, and even just
in conflicts in general.
In the book, I compare it to the
Israeli-Palestinian conflict,
which some people
think is kind of funny.
Leonard Lopate laughed about
that when I was on his show.
But it did remind
me of that in a way.
You can see that any time you're
in conflict about something,
especially if it's over
land, the same things
come up again and again.
So yeah, I think it
really helped me,
especially since it was such
a personal story, to step back
a little bit and see
it for the themes that
are recurring issues.
CHRIS MANNING: Any other
questions in the audience?
AUDIENCE: I guess my perspective
of the Wilderness Act,
or my understanding
of the intent
there is that it
protects areas such
that there's no human activity.
It belongs to nature.
And the primary thing
that it prevents against
is any sort of man-made building
or man-made-- and commerce,
that's definitely very man-made.
And commerce has a huge
impact on the environment.
So I was curious, one,
what your perspective was,
because it sounded
like you had changed
your perspective over time
through working in a newspaper
and what not.
But also broadly, is my
understanding of the Wilderness
Act, am I wrong there?
SUMMER BRENNAN:
No, you're right.
So the Wilderness Act, the
language is a little poetic.
I'm going to misquote it
here, but it's something
along the lines
of a wilderness is
an area where the works
of man are not dominant.
It's where the community
of nature is untrampled
and where man is a visitor
but does not remain.
So that's a mangled
version of that line.
But you're absolutely right.
It's that it's set
aside not for mankind.
We can visit.
We can go take a hike there,
but we can't ride our mountain
bikes, and there's not
supposed to be road,
not supposed to be buildings,
definitely not supposed
to be private businesses.
So I agree with that.
So that is what the
Wilderness Act was saying.
And when wilderness
is designated,
that is the purpose.
Along with that,
when that happened,
there were also writings
that spoke about it
in an idenic, humanless way
that other academics and critics
have argued erased and dismiss
the indigenous people that
were living here.
So I agree with what the
Wilderness Act says and sets
aside.
And I think that it can
be only strengthened
by acknowledging the
state of this land
before Europeans came
and colonized it.
Because I think those arguments
have been used to undermine it.
I feel there's been an
incomplete reevaluation
of our older wilderness ideas.
A positive reexamination
of those begins by saying,
well, just remember,
when you talk
about it being a landscape
where man isn't dominant,
there were people living here.
And that's true.
And part of, not wilderness,
but national parks
do protect cultural, historic
areas and things like that.
But anyway, I don't
know if that answers
your question a little bit,
but it's both of those things.
And I think it actually is
set aside not for people.
But we also need to
acknowledge that there
were people living here,
and you can't pretend
that that wasn't the case.
But we have to preserve
them, because there's people
everywhere.
And we do need to set aside
some places that are just
for natural ecosystems
to prepare them or let
them be intact.
AUDIENCE: Was
there actually case
in this story where Native
Americans were farming oysters?
SUMMER BRENNAN: No, actually,
as I found researching the book,
there were not
native populations
of oysters in the Bay Area,
at least as recently as
like over 1,000 years ago.
And I'd thought that there'd
been all these native oysters
in San Francisco Bay,
but actually they
were imported from
Washington, and New York,
and other parts
of the East Coast
by oyster businessmen
around the Gold Rush.
So that's in here too.
So there aren't any stories
of Native Americans harvesting
oysters, per se-- other things.
So I did talk to the chief
of the local tribe that
once lived in that area, and
it was really interesting.
Because he's a modern person
with modern businesses,
and yet, is tasked with carrying
on this spiritual heritage
of the place as well.
And so that was a really
interesting dichotomy
to encounter.
So I tried to incorporate
as many of those voices
as I could.
AUDIENCE: Are there any
similar cases to this
anywhere else in North America
or the rest of the world?
SUMMER BRENNAN: Well,
to this particular case,
not to my knowledge.
But there are
instances everywhere
where they have tried to
pry open protected areas
for different reasons.
We have people following the
news with the Arctic right now.
That's just with whether
that'll be wilderness
or what's going on.
So I didn't find a case
that was really like this.
There was an issue with
an Indian trader outpost
that people compared
this to, where
he was in a national park.
But it wasn't a
wilderness area, so it's
a bit of a different story.
AUDIENCE: It sounded
like this actually did
go through the court system.
SUMMER BRENNAN: Yes, it did.
AUDIENCE: It seems
conceptually like it
should be a pretty--
legally, it seems
like it if it's
in the wilderness,
it shouldn't be allowed.
The contract expired, and
so the contract's finished.
Was there any more legal
precedent that was set,
or was the court
case mostly just?
SUMMER BRENNAN:
Well, I mean, to be
spoilers-- I guess you can see
this in the news-- the oyster
farm was shut down,
and they did not
compromise the Wilderness Act.
So it did go through
the courts, and they
did petition the Supreme
Court, but they said no.
So it almost went is as high
as it could, but it didn't.
Many people agree with you that
it was absolutely clear-cut,
and it was only a lot
of smoke and mirrors
that confused it in the process.
Because it was
designated in '76 as
wilderness, and
the '64 Wilderness
Act dictates what wilderness is.
But there was confusion
in the process.
Not everybody agreed on
what wilderness means,
and that's why I
thought that getting
at the core of
what is wilderness
was such an important
issue in this book.
Because you had Senator
Dianne Feinstein writing
in defense of the
oyster farm, saying this
is not a wilderness area.
Even though it had
been designated as one
36 years prior, she said this
is not a remote wilderness.
There's cattle ranches and
dairy firms on all sides.
It's such and such
close to San Francisco.
It doesn't count.
And so that was what
was interesting to me.
Who decides what's wilderness?
And why does it
count as wilderness?
And that's why I think it is
such an important case going
forward, that you can't
just come and say,
well, actually this
place is a bit messed up,
so let's just scrap the whole
wilderness thing about it
and take it away.
So that was the argument.
OK, well, we said
it is wilderness,
but maybe we should
take that back,
because on second thought,
maybe not so much.
But it is wilderness.
They won.
CHRIS MANNING: So when the
Lunny family took over-- Is that
how you say it?
The Lunny?
SUMMER BRENNAN: The Lunny, yeah.
CHRIS MANNING: Yeah, the Lunny
family took over in, I think,
2005, was it?
SUMMER BRENNAN: Yeah,
sale closed in 2005.
CHRIS MANNING: Was
it their intent
to fight that concept
of the wilderness, or?
SUMMER BRENNAN: I
don't know if they
wanted to fight the
concept of the wilderness.
I know that they grew up-- Kevin
Lunny, who bought the farm,
grew up next door.
And his goal seemed to
be that he would really
work to clean up the
farm, and then it
would be able to continue.
It was a very
lucrative business.
I mean, recently, they
mentioned that last year, I
believe, the oyster farm
made about $5 million,
which isn't huge,
but it's a lot.
It's more than I make.
So there's a lot of
initiatives, and I
know that they were really
fond of the business.
And I think it seems
at their motivations,
they thought if
they could just show
that they were good
environmental stewards-- which
is why there were so many
fights about the science.
It's that they were
accused of being
poor environmental stewards.
They were like, how
can you say that?
We're working so hard
to clean up this area.
Because their predecessors had
a lot of environmental problems,
which I was really shocked,
the more research I
did, how extensive they were.
So they had a lot to clean up.
I think they just got
in over their head.
CHRIS MANNING: Any thoughts
for your next book?
Is that even--
SUMMER BRENNAN: I don't
know if I can talk about it.
So I do have a couple
things I've been working on.
I joked on Twitter about novel,
but don't hold your breath.
But I have a couple
nonfiction projects
that have been in the works,
that I pitched to my agent,
but not to any publishers.
So we'll see what
gets picked up next.
CHRIS MANNING: You
think nonfiction's
a medium that you're going to
stick with for a little bit?
SUMMER BRENNAN:
I really love it.
I love research.
I made a joke that
I could probably
write about research
libraries the way
some people write love poems.
And so that excites me.
And I like historical stuff.
So both of my next projects
are very historically based.
One of my favorite
writers is Erik Larson,
and I think he does
just a wonderful job
of finding all this great,
rich historical detail,
and telling it like a novel.
And so I'd like to get
better at doing that.
That's my plan.
CHRIS MANNING: Awesome.
Definitely a need for it.
AUDIENCE: In an ideal
world, or if you didn't
have to pay attention
to the legislation
or what not, what
do you think would
have been-- in your opinion,
what would you have done?
SUMMER BRENNAN: If I
was the deciding person?
AUDIENCE: If you
were the decider,
and there was no law that
you had to pay attention to.
SUMMER BRENNAN: So if there
was no wilderness designation?
See, that's an
interesting question.
Because if there wasn't a
wilderness designation--
I'm avoiding your
question a little bit--
I heard other people
argue that there's
no reason why the farm couldn't
have existed peacefully
as long as they always
followed the regulations.
My observation is that
they did not always
follow the regulations, and
that it's very difficult
to make all of your
employees follow the rules
and understand why you have
to follow particular rules,
because sometimes they
don't seem logical to you.
And you can say, look,
I know this environment.
I know what it needs.
But you're not always right.
So it's tricky.
So I don't know.
It's hard.
I mean, being a
local too, it was
very scary to come up
against information
that made it suggest maybe
the farm should have gone.
Because you know you're going
to get a lot of pushback.
But that was the impression
that I got by the end.
So I feel that the farm
itself, the infrastructure,
just wasn't environmentally
sound enough.
If they could have
completely restarted,
had tons of money to just pull
everything out of the estuary
and start over from scratch with
this totally green operation
that didn't have the decades
of environmental issues
and no wilderness
designation, and nobody ever
goes near the baby seals,
and, all that stuff,
they maybe could have
worked something out.
But unfortunately, that whole
scenario just wasn't the case.
CHRIS MANNING: Thanks so
much, Summer, for joining us.
And thanks for coming to Google.
SUMMER BRENNAN: Thanks so much.
CHRIS MANNING: Everybody
go buy the book
if you haven't already,
and support Summer's work.
It's great.
Thank you.
SUMMER BRENNAN: Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]